[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video gonna be discussing Snape
Dumbledore and one of the most iconic
scenes in the Harry Potter series
Dumbledore dying before we get started I
wanted to bring attention to the fact
that this video is going to be focusing
on how Snape used to fire Kedavra and
not why we know that Snape had to kill
Dumbledore in order to protect Draco
dumb model was already on death's door
from a curse and Draco had been assigned
by Voldemort the task of killing
Dumbledore in order to protect Traco
which Snape vowed to do he decided that
he would be the one to kill dumbledore
to protect draco soul this plan was
formulated by Dumbledore and Snape
beforehand with the sole objective of
protecting Draco if you don't mind dying
said Snape roughly why not let Draco do
it that boy's soul is not yet so damaged
said Dumbledore I would not have it
ripped apart on my account
when Snape finally does the deed and in
stumble does life uses none other than
the killing curse but what I found
highly unusual about this scene is that
Snipes use of the killing curse on
Dumbledore contradicts the very nature
of what we know to be the killing curse
the killing curse okay Avada Kedavra is
one of the three unforgivable curses
curses that are unforgivable
because of the sadistic nature Avada
Kedavra purpose is simple it causes the
victim to instantly die if you want to
kill your victim then this is the spell
to use the spell creates a blindingly
intense green bolt of light right before
the victim simply drops dead there are
two theories for how they died
the first claiming that the victims
internal organs cease to function have
to be instructed in the second claiming
the soul of the victim is magically
ripped from their body the capacity to
kill someone with a single incantation
is not something that should be taken
lightly and it's symbolic in that it
represents one of the darkest forms of
magic
however when casting such magic is
important to remember that there is a
certain level of intent required you
really have to mean what you're doing
and it's heavily suggested that in order
to perform these curses successfully you
need to really want to cause people pain
you need to really want to kill them you
simply can't perform
forgiveable curse like Avada Kedavra
without proper intent this is even
supported in the text when harry tries
to unsuccessfully used the Cruciatus
curse on Bellatrix hatred rosin harry
such as he had never known before he
found himself out from behind the
fountain and bellowed gruesome Bellatrix
screamed the spell had knocked her her
feet
but she did not rise and shriek with
pain as Neville had she was already back
on her feet
breathless no longer laughing Harry
dodged her behind the golden fountain
again her counterspell hit the head of
the handsome wizard which was blown off
and landed 20 feet away
gouging long scratches into the wooden
floor never used an unforgivable curse
before have you boy she yelled she had
abandoned her baby voice now you need to
mean them water you need to really want
to cause pain to enjoy it righteous
anger won't hurt me for long I'll show
you how it's done
shall I what give you a lesson Harry who
was absolutely beside himself with rage
was still unable to use the curse on
Bellatrix and that is because he's an
inherently good person so how on earth
was Snape good put to use Avada Kedavra
on Dumbledore Snape didn't hate their
model they're on the same side and Snape
clearly shows his reluctance to end
Dumbledore's life in the following
exchange after you have killed me
Severus you refuse to tell me everything
did you expect that small surface of me
snart's nape and real anger flared in
the thin face now you take a great deal
for granted Dumbledore perhaps I've
changed my mind you gave me your word
Severus we know that righteous anger is
not enough so how did Snape muster the
emotional ability to commit such an act
why was Dumbledore so confident and he
would be capable of even doing it I
think that what it boils down to is this
sure Harry was unable to cast crucio on
Bellatrix but that was because he lacked
the capacity to do what the spell was
created for torture had done model R
Snape to use crucial on him I'm not sure
the Duke would have been very effective
but that's not what he asked he asked
Snape to kill him what is Avada Kedavra
for killing and was the intent to kill
there yes because Snape knew that it was
necessary to protect Draco and he wanted
to fulfill Dumbledore's last request
additionally Snape is an immensely
powerful wizard who displays extreme
magical mastery time and time
he is such a profound understanding of
casting spells he knew exactly what was
required of him to cast a spell like
Avada Kedavra he knew exactly what he
needed to do emotionally to make the
spell happen probably honing all of his
repressed anger and pent up frustration
and he endured throughout his life a
Snape had probably respects somewhat or
more than anyone but he's also a
practical man who knew exactly what
needed to be done and that's it for this
video if you enjoy the content please be
sure to like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]
you